foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong I am your solo host today Mark
Ellis Jacqueline Coley on assignment at
one of those fancy film festivals that
you hear about it might be Venice where
a lot of stuff going on in Venice a lot
of stuff happening in Venice maybe it
was a Tribeca I think she's getting
ready for the Toronto International Film
Festival so Jacqueline Coley working
hard with the new movie so it's going to
be my duty today to look back after 30
years can you believe it's been 30 years
since this movie came out before we get
to that fun fact here if you're watching
us on peacock or any of our other
streaming platforms I am not at home I
am on the road in beautiful Las Vegas
Nevada thanks to the team at Brad
Garrett's comedy club for putting me up
and let me work with them all week long
Brad Garrett actually in towns are
getting to hang out with Brad again it's
just uh it's a great Club it's the best
operation in Las Vegas and for all
upcoming tour dates you can catch me at
markellis.live but that's for now that's
that's off of me as an adult this movie
reminds me of my childhood and maybe
coming into adulthood because this movie
it's not just for the kids it gets a
little dark and of course we're talking
about Batman Returns the sequel to
1989's Batman which starred Michael
Keaton and Jack Nicholson this time we
have Michael Keaton returning as Bruce
Wayne slash Batman Johnny giveaways
alter ego sorry about that Bruce and
then we also have Danny DeVito as the
penguin we have Michelle Pfeiffer as
Catwoman Christopher Walken is Max track
so many more it is the 30th anniversary
of Batman Returns this past June and
Batman day is on September 17th so it is
apropos that we talk about Batman
Returns which is 81 certified fresh on
the Tomato Meter with a 73 audience
score so much to talk about with this
movie I can't believe we're over 100
episodes into this podcast his legacy
and we haven't talked about Batman
Returns and more tragically it's the
first time time that we are welcoming
one of my favorite people on the I
shouldn't I shouldn't I'll say the
planet she's heading to this continent
but she's still in her Homeland in the
UK she is a presenter slash host for
everything from the BBC you've seen her
on a number of bathtub projects back to
Scotland
um which there's all these Baptists all
over the world that she was Illuminating
me about she is the one the only miss
Claire limb Claire you are currently
overseas but you are traveling to the
United States rather soon is that right
yes uh after I record this podcast not
right after but the next day I will be
in a plane in fact almost in LA and I'll
be there for about three weeks I'll be
in the state for three weeks I'm very
excited first time after the pandemic so
I've been filling in a lot of forms and
downloading a little covet passes and
all that kind of thing it's a changed
worlds but I'm very excited to come back
very excited it's very excited indeed
yeah you and I have been talking uh
really since the pandemic started about
when we can get you back over over to
this side of the Pod and so so excited
to see you in person in just a few days
but but right now I know you and I talk
about movies like this a lot where it's
movies that really influenced our
childhood and then especially when you
take an iconic character and Hell
characters when you talk about Batman
and Catwoman and penguin and you put
them all in this Vitamix together Batman
Returns it's actually higher than Batman
1989 according to the Tomato Meter 89 I
think is is like 73 and then if you
count this part of the quadrilogy which
I really don't but then you have Batman
Forever and Batman and Robin which are
both rotten movies according to the
Tomato Meter we should just call it
Batman and rotten at this point right so
um but but Batman Returns Claire I'm I'm
curious for you when you hear that 81
certified fresh in the Tomato Meter is
Rotten Tomatoes right about Batman
Returns or is Rotten Tomatoes wrong
that's right absolutely right
unequivocally right it's such a great
film
um I remember seeing this on VHS service
after it came out in the cinema when I
was a kid and I absolutely adored it I
fell in love with it immediately I'd
already seen Batman and I loved that
because it was the first time seeing
Batman and seeing a superhero like this
on screen my first superhero experience
was
um Superman for the Quest for Peace in
the cinema I was very young
terrible film terrible uh Superman film
to see in the cinema but I was really
obsessed with superheroes from that
point on so to see Batman and to see a
darker Batman and Batman Returns even
darker and even more Twisted it is so
simple it reeks of Tim Burton this film
and I love the characterizations I loved
how cartoonish they were I think for a
kid's uh my age back then I was very
very young maybe I was like with 10 or
something like that
um and yeah like I just love that
cartoonish feel and quality to it so it
really spoke to me despite the darkness
and things that we'll talk about later I
loved it yeah that Darkness you talk
about one of the takeaways from this
film still 30 years later and so I have
a story about why this movie came along
to me at the perfect time in my life it
was sort of a metaphor for where I was
in life so we'll get to that but for
right now I will say that look if if
you're judging this movie based on its
quality which we should right and we're
talking about the Tomato Meter number I
think 81 is fair however if I'm using
Batman 1989 and it's 73 scoring the
Tomato Meter as the barometer then this
movie Rotten Tomatoes got wrong because
it should be lower it should be lower
than the 1989 Batman I would still say
fresh but there's no world where I will
accept Batman Returns is higher on the
Tomato Meter than the Batman from 1989
that reinvented the superhero movie game
a lot like Superman one did a decade
before and then we got X-Men and blade a
decade after 89 ah stabbed his comic
book boom thanks to the Spider-Man
trilogy and then the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and all that good stuff so you
don't get any of these things that we
have today without these two former porn
movies in my humble opinion but for more
on why the critics maybe were feeling
this movie even more so than the first
Batman we now turn it over to one of our
favorite segments here Tim Ryan is our
expert review curation manager here at
Rotten Tomatoes and his segment two
minutes with 10 tells us what critics
were saying at the time 30 years ago a
Batman Returns His release take it away
Tim
Swift
[Music]
Batman Returns twice in the theater in
the summer of 1992. it made me really
sad but I went back because that's what
you did in the early 90s like I watched
Back to the Future Part three three
times in the theater
I think I saw True Lies twice in one day
with two sets of friends like maybe
people still do that but not for like
every movie anyway I was not alone in
thinking Batman Returns was especially
dark and Moody because a lot of
professional film critics in 1992 felt
the same way and even though I haven't
seen it in years I vividly remember a
number of the set pieces the
performances by Danny DeVito and
Michelle Pfeiffer and the Striking
visuals and yeah many of the critics
were struck by those elements as well
Batman Returns is certified fresh at 81
on the Tomato Meter with 88 reviews and
it has a 73 audience score
so what did the critics have to say in a
fresh review Gene Siskel the Chicago
Tribune wrote this time the richness of
the Batman movie is not in its
production design but rather in Burton's
and screenwriter Daniel waters Freudian
view of adult human behavior
however in a rotten review Roger Ebert
of the Chicago Sun Times wrote Tim
Burton's Batman Returns even more than
the original Batman is a dark brooding
film filled with hurt and fear childhood
wounds and festering adult resentments
it is also a most intriguing movie great
to look at fun to talk about there is no
doubt Burton is a gifted director but is
he the right director for Batman
the Rotten Tomatoes critics consensus
reads director Tim Burton's dark
brooding atmosphere Michael Keaton's
work as a tormented hero and the
Flawless casting of Danny DeVito as the
Penguin and Christopher Walken as well
Christopher Walken make the sequel
better than the first so that's Batman
Returns let's kick it back to Mark even
though we're in the midst of a heat wave
it's going to be a hot time on the cold
town tonight back to you
this podcast needs an enema well I guess
that's more the first movie it's
interesting to hear that Gene Siskel
loved this movie and Roger Ebert not so
not so maybe we got the one thumb up for
this movie we'll have to check if Roger
ended up getting that old Thumb in the
right direction so let's head right into
movie talk
thank you
it's so funny Claire here and Tim Ryan
talk about how he went to go see True
Lies twice in one day I did that with
Die Hard with a Vengeance my auntie took
me to see it that morning and then I
took the rest of the family to see it
that night have you ever seen a movie
twice in one day no no I've no I've seen
plenty of movies many times but not
twice in one day although True Lies
would be one that I would see twice in
one day True Lies is one of my favorite
Arnold films if I know there's Running
Man and all these things but like I love
True Lies I love big schlocky 90s action
films I'm a very simple girl I'm a very
very cheap simple date uh Mark just send
me to like an army film and grab me a
beer that's basically it that's like the
perfect that's the key to going out with
Claire is you take her to a movie in the
morning and then you just keep seeing
the same movie over and over again you
just stay in the theater and you just
let them clean the theater around us I
would say true eyes is one of Arnold's
best efforts certainly better than his
turn is Mr Freeze in Batman and Robin it
was fun to see Arnold and Batman and
Robin but by that point the movies had
just so separated themselves from what
these first two Tim Burton films were
and that that's sort of what I was
getting at in in the intro is that
Batman 1989 I went to go see with my
family because I was obviously I was too
young back then to go by myself we just
moved to a new town I discovered movie
theater nachos for the first time with
Batman 1989 it's a great formative
experience but then Claire you know you
grow up so fast in such a short period
of time when you're preteen into
teenager and I was 11 years old when
Batman Returns came out and so I went to
the theater by myself with my friends
obviously you have your parent drop you
off but then you're going to the movie
by yourself and so that's why I feel
like Batman Returns so much darker so
much more adult and it's almost like hey
now Mark's going to the movies by
himself with his friends and he's being
trusted out there in the world without
Parental Guidance constantly looking
over him and then this movie comes on
and my God people say say oh yeah I can
see how it's dark or it's going it is
dark it is a very dark movie did you see
this in a theater did somebody take you
to see it or did you did you first catch
it uh in in home media afterwards I
caught out on VHS and I watched it on my
own my parents didn't have any my
parents let me watch whatever I I wanted
pretty much
um it wasn't the social media days of oh
my God everything's bad and it was just
like here's some here's RoboCop watch
that you know you are a nine watch it
here is Batman Returns watch that I
noticed the the dark sexual under or
overtones and all the darkness
um a lot stronger as an adult actually
than I was than I did as a kid because
as a kid I'm looking at the costumes I'm
looking at the characterization Catwoman
is so Catwoman Batman is so boring I
guess in this film he doesn't say a word
until about 30 to 35 minutes in and then
you've got penguin and he's this
grotesque creature that it lives
underground with like a family of
penguins and these circus people and the
clowns and everything like that match
wreck the corporate villain what a great
I love a corporate villain Mark like I
really really do like verhoven usually
does corporate villains really well like
Total Recall and things like that but I
I never really realized until later I
thought yeah Christopher Walken he plays
this break of trumpian character
Charming for the people completely
complete sociopath so all of these
things sort of demarcated in my little
childlike brain were really good to
watch as a kid you know perfect watch to
watch as a kid I didn't notice all the
darkness did they make you feel funny
Mark when you watched Batman Returns did
you get some funny feelings well it gave
me a funny feeling in especially in
terms of it maybe it wasn't the sexual
Awakening that Bruce Wayne was having at
the time with Selena Kyle and then I I
do love when when they they're having a
moment together and his place and he
brings up Vicky and that's like the only
mention of Vicki Vale Kim Basinger's
character from the first one and Selena
called his laughs and she's like Vicky
was she which airline did she work for
something like that and you know the
real darkness of this movie not just
comes from the subject matter which is
super gloomy but you also have this
marriage of the story with the backdrop
of Christmas and we're lighting a
Christmas tree and that really sets our
events in motion is that this Christmas
tree lighting goes horribly wrong you
have all these clowns that are just
attacking people left and right we don't
know where they're coming from we don't
know why they're there there's rumors of
this thing in the sewer that turns out
to be Oswald cobblepot slash penguin and
we're off and running but right from the
start and this is one of my favorite
scenes I'll say in this air is the
opening credits because I love that
Danny Elfman score it's one of my
favorite movie scores in history we do
get to see a brief appearance by
penguin's dad Paul Reubens Pee-wee
Herman and this is important to know
because this was right at after the
Scandal and quotes broke that Paul
Rubens went into an adult film theater
and was a little too friendly with
himself and that was so so Peewee was
sort of persona non grata for a while
but to see him in this movie he was
unrecognizable they have a child there
are these rich waspy types and so they
don't want the kid because it's not a
perfect baby they put it into a basket
they send it down a river like the
opposite of the Moses story in the Bible
and that is our opening credits scene is
watching a baby carriage flow deeper and
deeper into the sewer Claire that's my
argument that says this movie doesn't
feel dark this movie is dark you forgot
to mention four words Mark baby in a
cage they put the blooming baby
the baby is in a cage and then three
other words baby eats cat oh my God like
the baby eats the cat
it doesn't see the cat grabs the cat I
assume that it's feasting on the cat
it's definitely not petting the cat
um but yeah like that I think the
opening is really powerful actually
because it sets the tone for the whole
film you you open to that score as you
mentioned incredibly powerful and
memorable score it's like this Baroque
dark fairy tale you know and it's got
that kind of Christmas feel but it was
released in June right is it a Christmas
film though Mark is that a Christmas
film
it's one of those great debates that
we'll have because you know Die Hard is
now considered a Christmas classic it
came out in like I think it came out the
beginning of the Summer with the weapon
I think came out in March and that's
considered a Christmas movie so it
really is Christmas all the year around
in Hollywood but no it doesn't feel like
a Christmas movie at all it it feels
like a movie that lives in the world of
Batman more so from the graphic novels I
would say than the the lighter comic
books that were the basis for the 1960s
Batman TV show in the movie is there a
scene that you would point to in this
movie Claire and you're sort of like
that that is why I feel like this movie
has earned its perch as a certified
fresh film on the Tomato Meter oh
there's a there's a few scenes but I'm
gonna choose I'm going to choose a sort
of a scene that people might not think
of straight away and it's he's seen
almost at the very end of the film
and it's a ballroom seam Max wreck is
holding a party and Selena is there and
Bruce is there he's decided to go along
because oh well Selena's going to be
there so he might see her he sees her
coming down from the staircase and she
looks absolutely gorgeous
they meet and they dance and we have to
keep in mind she's kind of been driven
mad by this idea that she needs to get
back at Max for killing her essentially
and as she was reinvented as Catwoman
she has a gun he's getting a bit nervous
and then they're under the mistletoe and
then they say this famous line that they
said earlier in the film
um which is very important because it's
it's the the line that basically shows
that they know when they understand who
they actually are it's about the kiss
under the mistletoe and you know a kiss
is deadly if you mean it that kind of
thing and um they suddenly look at each
other
and they're like do we start fighting
like what do we do now
who gets under the mistletoe
you know
mistletoe can be deadly if you eat it
Savannah
that seems so great to me because it
shows how powerful Michelle Pfeiffer is
uh acting as actually and how powerful
the chemistry is between Bruce and
Selena we see the chemistry between
Catwoman and Batman but that chemistry
is very important and they are
incredible actors and amongst all the
craziness and the Darkness and the
cartoonish characters that's a very
serious and a very well acted moment and
that for me stands out as something that
makes the film quality it's not just a
silly cartoonish film you've got some
peripheral acting in there as well and
great storytelling and you also have
that sort of blurring the lines between
hero villain anti-hero and that was
another sort of Discovery for me as a
boy was watching this and being like you
know you walk in and you're like okay I
know Batman's a good guy then everybody
else is a bad guy right and so Catwoman
is a villain but no no you watch it and
in Catwoman recasting and retelling
since then Catwoman is basically just
another hero in the bad man the most
recent one that we got with the the
great uh Zoe Kravitz in the role and so
to see Michelle Pfeiffer play off of
Bruce Wayne and have that tension you're
talking about back and forth It's so
well done and she owns so many of my
favorite moments in this movie from when
we get to meet her as just this nebbish
this sort of squirrely secretary who has
big ideas but just knows nobody's going
to listen to him she gets home she's got
a lonely life she's pretty much me
getting back to my place and you know
honey I'm home oh wait I'm not married
and just living by yourself and the
hello there Neons and then she comes
back as Catwoman after Shrek pushes her
out the window and she gets revived by
all these Neighborhood Cats she comes
back and she knocks out two of the
letters and it says hell here and I'm
like oh that is so cool I see what you
did there Michelle Pfeiffer I see what
you did there Catwoman but one of the
coolest announcement and arrivals that
there's a new character you in the town
of Gotham is when she blows up that
store front and then just gives a simple
meow because it's like hey there's a new
person you're going to have to tussle
with whether you're Batman whether
you're penguin whether you're anybody
I'm my own person this is the
destruction I'm capable of and the
storefront blows up it's a beautiful
destructive sequence 100
I think of her first before Batman and
the Penguin although each one of them
are great I'd say the like Michael
Keaton and Batman are so slightly weaker
in this film
um he's he doesn't have as big a role
he's quite silent and he's quite boring
and actually it's the other two that are
an even Max Shrek Christopher Walken
that are bringing the kind of energy but
Michelle Pfeiffer is incredible she's
such a sort of before we were having
um conversations about feminism and
before it was a hashtag and before it
was something that we talked about
online she's such a strong feminist icon
in this film and she says things like
you know the law doesn't apply to men
like him and you know she's trying to
fight against him by him she means Max
Shrek her boss you know when she's
trying to kind of like fight against
that and fight against all of these
elements to try and be the hero or the
anti-hero and also the woman that she
wants to be and the way that she
transforms as you said from the
squirrely kind of secretary then next
day she comes in wearing the same
clothes which is completely different
she's strutting around you can't take
your eye off her she's become the focus
of the room so yeah she is incredible
every scene with Catwoman even like the
the sort of the scene where she's on top
of Batman and then she sort of just
licks his face you know when you're like
oh oh wow okay here we go like and it's
really and I think that went on I think
in terms of the comics after this film
influenced a lot of artists and
influenced a lot of comic book writers
because Tim Burton famously said yeah I
wasn't really into Like Comics you know
I was really into like the economics in
general like it does feel like he's
taken the essence of what these
characters are and he's just Twisted it
in his mind and and basically put them
through the Burton machine and that's
how they've come out is little Burton
sausages you know so like that's how
he's basically done it and I think
that's great and I think it's absolutely
fine to do that Nolan has his Tech uh
Burton had his take as well we've had
Schumacher the less said about the other
one's the bear but she would
Schumacher's sake as well as and then we
had bat nipples at one point Jesus
Christ so you know so we've had all
sorts of different takes on Batman but I
like it when a director takes something
and makes it their own if it's not for
you and that's absolutely fine there's
so many Batman movies now to choose from
so it's fine and he gave his actors such
a wonderful sandbox to play and like
we're talking about Michelle Pfeiffer's
Catwoman the scene where she says maybe
I'll just give myself a bath right here
and then for a moment we're like what's
about to happen and she just starts
licking herself like a cat and that so
turns on penguin who is just this Primal
force of darkness and it just so twisted
and there's just no Redemption because
he's been spurned his whole life and he
literally had to be taken in by penguins
at such an early age of existence and
when we see him emerge as an adult in
his final penguin form it's such a great
performance again Danny DeVito crafted
and it's so menacing and but there's
there's times when I mean you gotta feel
for Oswald cobblepot and it makes them
such a three-dimensional villain he's
still clearly in the realm of a villain
but it's not a villain where you can't
at least understand where they're coming
from and and that's why he wins over the
hearts of the town because they stage a
rescue of a baby but more importantly he
just wants to know who his parents are
he wants to find his parents he wants to
find out why he was rejected by his
parents and so you can relate to that
and then we get to some of the more
grotesque violence scenes I remember
there was an uproar amongst parents a
lot of parents probably like my parents
my parents didn't really care but they
would drop their kids off for the movies
to see the Batman movie and trusted the
Batman movie is going to be no worse
than a PG-13 but the scene in particular
that parents lost their minds at was
when Danny DeVito gets upset at some
other sort of cranky either politician
or a lobbyist and he bites his nose and
and it's it's it should there's blood
just shooting out of his nose and
parents thought that was a bridge too
far this is in the days when Mortal
Kombat was all the rage of the arcades
and there's blood gushing out of every
orifice and it was just too much for our
Virgin Eyes but really the whole
character of Pangolin was such this like
freakish like adult themed character
that kids if anything were just gonna be
scared by he's quite looking at him
though with idle eyes he is quite a
pathetic character actually as you said
he's twisted and strange and quite sad
you know because he just wants to find
his parents he thinks that you know the
world above is for him but he isn't
quite human as he says it's actually in
the end up it's the world Below in the
his penguin family and the circus family
um that there are actually these family
facts it's just the penguins at the end
this procession of penguins that sort of
drag him into the water when when he
meets his end so it's it's quite I
wasn't very scared by the penguin when I
was younger because I as I mentioned
before it's in all sorts of films like
Robocop and all sorts my mum like sat me
in front of all sorts of horror films
and things so and it's funny that
parents got upset by the biting of the
nose and not the the whips and the
licking of the PVC and things like that
it's like oh no that poor man's nose we
must cause an uproar everyone Brands
pull out immediately so I find it that's
quite it's funny as well when I was
thinking about
um the Uproar caused what makes us
squeamish now is so completely different
to 30 years ago you know it's that's so
tame this film is very tame actually
when you look back at it and for people
to be so upset about it is incredible to
me and it just shows how much we've
pushed the boat out further and further
and further I don't think there's ever
been I'm thinking about the rest of the
Batman films and I don't think there's
any one Batman film I've thought is
particularly very violent in terms of
its content I think we're so used to
just seeing things now which is kind of
sad actually I kind of want to be
shocked do you want to be shocked mark
because I kind of want to be shocked
again you know what shocks me about this
movie it's not necessarily the violence
we'll get into some of the action
sequences too but it is that moment you
talked about with the penguin that's the
one that always stands out to me is I
think of the nose biting it's because of
the Uproar but then I think of when when
penguin does end up meeting his demo
eyes and it's it I get oddly emotional
watching the Penguins walk their daddy
into his watery grave and then he just
slowly descends into this into this
black water and I I feel bad for the
Penguins Claire this was their this was
their daddy this was their Poppy the
sister poppy oh okay Mark wait hold on
okay I've got a problem with that scene
first of all okay oh my God Mark okay so
first of all it's a sad scene it's the
way the way he dies and just drops to
the ground fine and he's got the you
know the saliva that dark saliva coming
out of his mouth he's fully animal at
that point bam drops the ground
you can't I guess has Penguins Sons as
you would see Mark coming out of nowhere
and they're kind of okay now this is
very pedantic but I'm a very pedantic
sort of person they drag him along with
their flippers but they're not really
touching his body they're kind of how
are they sliding them with their weird
penguin strength they're just kind of
walking alongside I'm sorry the whole
scene is just rubbish it just doesn't
work and I watched it and I spun it back
and I was like
it's very unrealistic they couldn't even
grab him they couldn't hold on to his
back they got no fingers they've got no
opposable thumbs this is nonsense that
was the thing that made me think it was
nonsense it was the bond of Love queer
they loved him so much it transcended
the physical property and they were able
to drag him probably also with some
water with some slickness with the
downhill grade going right into the
water and
um but then you're also in the back of
your mind you're thinking okay wait a
minute what's gonna happen with Bruce
and Catwoman here and so I'll also say
one of my favorite scenes you know I
look back on this movie it's not
necessarily this giant piece or a
climactic moment this is one of the
first to my knowledge not even a
post-credits scene but just the tease
like at the very end of a movie like oh
we may not be done yet because we think
that Catwoman's used up all our lives
and she dies too but no right at the end
of the movie you see her head pop up
from behind and it's so cool it's such a
cool thing to walk out of the theater
with they're like oh we might get
another Adventure how robbed do we feel
now that we didn't instead of Batman
Forever we didn't get a movie that would
feature once again Bruce Wayne played by
Michael Keaton and Michelle Pfeiffer's
Catwoman I know oh my goodness that was
a body double as well because she wasn't
available and seen and I think it cost
them millions of dollars just to do that
and seem like or love a lot of money
um I honestly would have loved to have
just seen a standalone film
with Catwoman I don't even think we
would need Batman we could actually just
have Catwoman that would have worked but
it was in development hell I think for
like 10 years like a lot of these
amazing things that we read about are
you know just lots of probably internal
politics and things like that so it's
such a shame because the next time we
saw Catwoman alone in the movie was uh
the sort of Halle Berry and nothing
against Halle Berry she's an absolutely
fantastic actress but no I'm just gonna
say no just no no CGI Halle Berry
crawling long rooftops like some kind of
like strange cat spider it was terrible
oh my God so yeah that next time I mean
then that just ruined it but then you
know we got Zoe Kravitz recently and I
think although I'm not a big fan I know
that's an unpopular opinion I'm not a
big fan of that Batman movie The Todd
Phillips movie not but I thought they
did a decent job and I thought Zoe
Kravitz was very very good but whereas
the Tim Burton film was dark and it's
cartoonish and it was very stylized you
know because it was very Tim
burton-esque it kind of worked for me
when I saw the new Batman film I was
like oh my gosh this is so emo
everything was so emo at one point in
the new film just to digress Alfred
wakes up from a coma and instead of you
know uh Bruce Wayne going oh Alfred are
you okay he's just like so
immediately like outfits he's so dark to
the point that that's almost cartoonish
and a kind of different way that it
doesn't work for me so that's why Tim
Burton's works because it's so of a
style and a time and place but I could
very easily draw a line between Batman
Returns specifically and the Batman in
terms of a darkness and a feel and a
tone the Batman Returns Disney a little
bit more into the campiness and that
speaks to the Tim Burton of it all but
where whereas I feel like both of these
movies Batman 1989 and Batman Returns
feel very like a Tim Burton film he puts
his signature stamp on it I feel like
Batman had more of a fun to it and more
of a white-heartedness and and that
might just be attributed to the fact
that we're getting to know Batman and so
you got to ease us into it a little bit
even though Batman has his own tragic
backstory so does Jack Napier for that
matter uh becoming the Joker but then we
also get Robert wool's reporter and he's
a great comic relief in that movie and
him hitting on Vicky Vicky going after
Batman like there's a lot more fun you
Joker running around cracking jokes and
that's not really the style in the same
way the Catwoman who it was very punny
and penguin can be very punny but
they're more doing it for their own
entertainment not necessarily to
entertain us the audience and when you
talk about the audience Claire I think a
lot of people were left somewhat cold
not just because of the weather in
Gotham but because Batman returned or
Diddy because he's just sort of a fly on
the wall for most of this movie do we
get shortchanged with not enough actual
planet or was it worth it to make him
the backup singer to Catwoman and
penguin I think they should have called
the film Batman and then you know in
parentheses was there because
Batman feels like a bit player in this
you know and I guess I understand why
people would have felt like they got
shortchanged I didn't feel like that
personally as a fan even now and I
didn't feel like that as a kid because
it was there was a lot for your visual
feasts for the eyes like you know my
brain was like sparking off when I
watched this I was like Wow and this and
that and this but it wasn't really a
Batman film and like the each share
equal billing on the poster you see them
on the poster just that famous poster
with three of them they're sort of heads
and you're one after the other they are
equal and one you know and they're all
the same there's um there's a quote that
uh penguin says to Batman in this film
and he says you're just jealous because
I'm a genuine freak and you have to wear
a mask and that's kind of how I feel
about these three characters they're all
freaks each and every one of them it's
not just Batman being up here or cat
when they're paying one is all of them
every single one so I can understand why
people were being shortchanged but it
felt more sort of theatrical and service
so I didn't really mind that so you know
if you want to go watch like a Batman
film there's plenty of proper Batman
films that you could go watch to just
see him brood over the death of his
parents again that's what's your ball go
do that but I was about I'll get a bit
bored of that sometimes so I want
something a bit different yeah it was
also refreshing just to see somebody
else have some parent issues that being
penguin most notably exactly you can't
talk about Batman Returns though and not
at least mention Christopher Walken
because this was the entry point for I
would say most everyone in my generation
and probably younger too this was the
first time we met Christopher Walken I
had no idea who Christopher Walken is he
maybe would Vaguely Familiar to me the
name Max Shrek obviously taken from a
very old-timey sort of actor and you
have this character is really one of the
I would say there's multiple glues to
this story but Max Shrek is really some
of the the most connective of the tissue
in this movie because he is now going to
have a storyline with penguin he
obviously relates to Catwoman because he
pretty much is responsible for the
formation of Catwoman he's going to be
butting heads in a boardroom with Bruce
Wayne and so max Shrek really is
integral to the telling of this story
because he sort of represents the power
of the penguin craves but he also
represents a thing for the city of
Gotham and sort of the The Cloud of
secrecy and the cover-ups that you get
at the highest Halls of Gotham City
absolutely absolutely I think you've
just described that perfectly as to why
I think in terms of script writing it's
actually a really good film if you take
away everything else the way that the
characters are written the layers that
they're that they have to them and the
way that they're all Interlink and then
all Interlink with Max Shrek who
actually is at the top here they've all
got something against Max and he is
connecting all of them it's actually
very well written so you can say what
you like about this film but the
screenwriting is actually very very good
there are some weak moments in the
script you know which I could talk about
later but in terms of that interlinking
of story The layering and having it
quite a tight story as well at no point
do I go wait a minute but wait a minute
but wait a minute I'm never really doing
that and I do that with a lot of other
films but with this I took what I was
given and I liked what I was given and I
love those layers and I like that
connection so it's well written Mark
well written we talk about the Tim
Burton of it all and some of the
backstory here with Batman Returns is
that obviously Batman 1989 comes out it
dominated that entire summer you
couldn't go anywhere without seeing the
Batman logo hearing Prince music and
then obviously there's going to be
Studio pressure to make a sequel like
hey we need to turn this thing over
faster Tim Burton was very hesitant to
make this or any sequel to any of his
movies because he just did quote didn't
find sequels all that interesting and so
there's an early version of of a script
or a treatment that was from Sam ham I
believe and that was going to involve
originally they thought about expanding
on the character of two face which was
Harvey Dent played by Billy D Williams
in the first movie that would have been
interesting but the studio really wanted
to focus on penguin because they looked
at him as the next uh sort of best
villain for Batman after the Joker and
then they wanted to incorporate Catwoman
those early treatments didn't really
Pass the Mustard for Tim Burton and so
then they start working on another
version of it and it's
you take what Batman 1989 was and Burton
said he didn't want any connection to
that movie for Batman Returns and I
found that so interesting that he
purposely wanted to separate from it so
that very quick reference to Vicki Vale
is the only thing that you hear in
Batman and besides the familiarity of
Michael Keaton's face which again we
don't get to see talk nearly as much as
we did in the first movie that's really
the only connection so that's why those
movies feel so wildly different from one
another even though it's the same
director and even though they both feel
like they're in that director's
wheelhouse I still go with Batman 1989
but I certainly see the appeal and the
influence of Batman Returns I think
Batman Returns ironically may be the
more influential movie with modern comic
book movie culture it's in interesting
because I mean I love the first Batman
movie you know like when I saw that it
blew my little mind as well you know it
was the first time seeing all those
characters on screen but it's an
interesting one because you know Batman
Returns really is an example of a film
uh where the director when you give them
full Freedom you know and he'd hired a
lot of his people he told the studio I
just want freedom to do what I want to
do and that's what we get and it was
popular nonetheless and that's a really
interesting concept yes the the first
film was also popular and it's still
directed by the same director but I
think that sometimes Studios don't take
risks this is quite a risky film and the
fact that they give them the money to
make it if we think about all the
elements that we talked about I mean
McDonald's were pulling out they didn't
want their Happy Meals associated with
this film eventually you know but I also
read that the original script had a
Catwoman and the Penguin teaming up
together to search for Hidden Treasure
like a bunch of weird Pirates it's like
like I was like what actually but now I
kind of feel like I would like to see
that film
um probably would enjoy it better than
Pirates of the Caribbean and can you
imagine them like searching forever
treasure the penguin with his little Peg
Leg would be absolutely amazing I
actually can they should have given him
the the submarine that Burgess Meredith
had in the 1966 TV and movie version of
Bad Man I mean because they always
teamed up together back in the day you
always had Batman going up again it was
Batman and Robin going up against in the
movie especially got Catwoman you got
penguin you got Riddler and you got
Joker they always had such a great time
together it's a shame we never got that
entire Rogues Gallery all in one movie
but as the next two Joel Schumacher
Batman films taught us maybe it would
have been cramming a little bit too much
in there and so if if we take a step
back we just look at this as a whole I
will also say another star of this movie
to me at the time anyway was the
Batmobile because Batman's been making
some modifications to that baby the the
flame trick that he does the the fact
that he's got the missiles on it and it
can rotate he's got this little thing
that comes out of the bottom and it
rotates I know McDonald's was pulling
out of this movie because they thought
it was too dark for kitties there's a
lot of toys that you can sell just based
off the new revamped the Batman Returns
Batmobile might be my favorite Batmobile
of them all does Claire Lim have her
favorite Batmobile ready for the world
to hear it's the same as yours I'm going
to do a person we had like a Batmobile
toy from that film we got a lot of toys
from that film and I had the I was
really I mean you don't know how
obsessed I am I was with the first and
second film my toys I had a t-shirt side
like the clothing I had like pajamas I
thought the whole the whole lot and the
Batmobile as well my I didn't have a
doll house when I was a kid because I
was like a little tomboy nerd I had like
a car park and I used to just line up
the cars in the car park perfectly
because that was my that was my
dollhouse Mark I had a car park so like
I had like all these little Batmobile
things as well I had a sticker book and
when I had to click the stickers as well
like from the first and the second movie
so I just think it looks the design is
really Sleek it looks really cool and
there's loads of great modifications as
you said but we can see that as soon as
they put like a little one little
Contraption or device in it messed up
completely messed up the Batmobile was
completely messed up penguins taken over
the Batmobile and it's and that's it's
game over so it's not you know what the
design is flimsy at best mark would you
agree it's quite flimsy another great
performance by Michael Guff as Alfred
where and I do love the scene it just it
tells me so much about Bruce Wayne and
his relationship to the World At Large
where I think it's gazpacho or it's
something else it's a cold soup that
Alfred made for for dinner
um for for Bruce Wayne and Bruce Wayne
is obviously in the Batcave and he's
working hard he's studying these
villains and he serves him the bowl of
soup and he takes a Michael Keaton's
takes the bites of it he spits he's like
Alfred the soup's cold and he's like it
serves cold and then he thinks about for
a minute then he just starts eating it
and it's like food is just fuel for this
guy this guy has no enjoyment of
anything because he's so obsessed
fighting crime and he's just so deep
into his Batman pathos that he can't
find any sort of hope it didn't work out
with Vicki and I'm sorry Bruce but you
know you gotta stop missing the forest
for the trees Selena Kyle was right
there she's more like you than you want
to admit and that maybe they should have
skipped off into the sunset like they
did we think at the end of The Dark
Knight Rises where they just go off on
some foreign country so I guess my
question to you as as we put a button in
this in this movie in this conversation
Claire where are if that's the end of
Batman's story and we never see another
movie where are Batman and where are
Catwoman today are they hanging out do
they know each other are they keeping
tabs on each other did one of them just
go off to live in Barbados for the rest
of their lives where are they now well
I've got a question for you after I
answer your question okay where would
they be now they would definitely not be
together and they would not be married I
think it would be one of those toxic
relationships that they keep going back
to you know it's like oh God I just
can't I just can't quit you you know one
of those kind of relationships you know
what I'm talking about Mark is like oh I
really keep going for the same type oh
there you are again that kind of thing
and so that keeps happening and he
finding themselves single and they just
don't admit that perhaps maybe they
should just get it together because
they're also commitment Forbes I'm gonna
just put that on them as well I feel
like there'd be commitment folds or
maybe they should just get a dog or a
cat oh well she's got a cat he should
just get a dog and then that's that
problem solved but I had the question
for you mark so
and I don't know like because you seem
like a nice wholesome type mark from
what you've said you seem very wholesome
you know you were ignoring all the
sexiness and you're going wow this is a
cool explosive sin as a young lad
you weren't looking at all the sexy
stuff Vicki Vale
barcelina Kyle
oh
it would you rather go on a lovely a
lovely wholesome date with Mark
I I would be tempted I would be tempted
to go with Selena Kyle here's why I
don't Claire because I need to trust you
when I'm asleep okay I need I'm gonna
have a great time with both of y'all and
I dare say I might have a more fun wild
time in certain rooms of the house with
Catwoman than I would with Vicki Vale
but I need to trust you when I am asleep
and I don't like sleeping with one eye
open I want to sleep as heavy as
possible and so in the same way that
Vicki probably left Bruce because she
couldn't trust him when she slept
because she wakes up in the first movie
in the middle of the night and she sees
this dude she just hooked up with
hanging upside down swinging like what
the hell is wrong with this guy I would
feel that way about Catwoman I feel like
I'd wake up in the middle of the night
there'd be cats in bed everywhere and
Molly would be getting in a fight with
them and Selena would just be staring at
me like it it would just be it'd be a
weird relationship but I think that you
you're on to something as far as the
toxicity yet the I can't quit you
mentality between Batman and Catwoman
here's my here's my fan Theory and you
and I should work on this fiction
together
I feel like they have an arrangement I
feel like Bruce Wayne and Selena Cowell
have an arrangement going forward that
they're just going to live their lives
and not interfere with each other but
then the holidays come around and if
neither one of them has found anybody by
Christmas
they're gonna link up just for like that
week or two they're just gonna hook up
it's gonna be wild sex they're gonna
watch a lot of college football bowl
games they're going to celebrate the
holidays there's going to be mistletoe
everywhere and then New Year's Day get
out of my life I'll see you next year if
you don't find anybody better you know
what that sounds like a great time to me
Mark I'm not gonna lie uh not gonna lie
quite enjoying being single so you know
quite quite like the idea of just like
having a nice three day break shall we
say mistletoe all over the place and
just you know when he's watching
football it's like I'm just gonna like
bake or something we could just pet my
cat and uh I'll see you tonight at 11
o'clock
like the love and Affinity that people
have for Batman Returns 30 years later
and we're still talking about it and I
will say regardless of where you think
it falls in the Tomato Meter I just
think as as a standalone Adventure in a
very uh nutty Gothic world I feel like
Batman Returns certainly still holds up
as well as any movie that's based on a
comic book or really any action movie
any film from the early 90s period I
think it's right up there with the
Terminator twos of the world where you
can still watch it today and get a hell
of a lot out of it and see the influence
that it's had on movies ever since its
release back in June of 1992 so that's
gonna do it for movie talk and we our
mailbag less we'll be back with mailbag
in a couple weeks I hear but in the
meantime Brian why don't you just hit
that outro music for us
[Music]
uh we do miss Michael Keaton as Batman
and Michelle Pfeiffer's Catwoman you
know what was really cool Claire is uh I
know I I don't know if you've ever had
the opportunity to go to San Diego
Comic-Con but when when you're there and
you're in hallway it's like the big Hall
with like you know 6 000 people in there
they do these big movie panels the crowd
is really in tune to like who has paved
the way for comic book movies as we know
them now so I was there I think it was
2014 and they were doing a panel for
Robocop and Michael Keaton's in that
movie they introduced Michael Keaton
Standing Ovation and it's because
they're excited to see RoboCop a little
bit but they're giving him a standing
ovation for who he was as Batman same
thing happened a couple years later when
Michelle Pfeiffer was revealed to be in
the cast of Ant-Man Standing Ovation
because they're excited to see her in
Ant-Man and she's the great Michelle
Pfeiffer but she was Selena Kyle and she
really turned the role of Catwoman on
its ear and really gave us all something
to think about and to grow from so it
was a really cool experience and I hope
you had good experience and I still
can't believe that we're over 100
episodes into this show and this is the
first time having you it was such a
treat to see and hear you once again
Claire I know it's been absolutely
wonderful like I mean anytime I get to
like narrow down over movies is
completely fine with me so if you will
have me back to gas off about whoever
else and whoever else then I am happy to
return that'd be great and then maybe we
can start writing this fan fiction I
feel like there's something because I
think we need to we start our Rotten
Tomatoes a fan fiction pod I would love
to do that or just what what would
happen in a sort of Black Mirror world
with these weird characters we have to
do it Mark what would happen and in
clear and I was podcasting history we've
already written a great sequel to Point
Break and now we're coming up with new
Batman material and so we'll have you
back we'll call it Claire whim returns
but we'll give you many more lines than
Batman got when he returned in this
movie so in the meantime I know you're
you have a lot of travels coming up
really soon uh where can all the kids
find you on social media I know you have
active in the twitch world uh what's
sort of the the Claire limb Hub right
now the clear limb hub
sad and lonely place
so at Twitter is just weakler
um as in we small
um and then the rest Instagram twitch uh
it's weakler here and if you want to
find out more about meets weclear.com
there you go weclear.com that's w-e-e as
in Peewee right by Paul Reubens the
father of the very terrible father of
penguin slash Oswald cobblepot uh Claire
last thing before we let you go here do
you have any maybe more current
recommendation as far as something that
you recently watched it could be a movie
it could be a show something that you've
been streaming what is sort of on your
watch list that you checked out now you
think everybody else should go give a
watch right okay so it's not super
recent but if you if you can catch this
TV show Barry
Barry is if something it's got that
Breaking Bad feel for me that oh my
goodness what's happening next it's uh
short episodes and there's not many
seasons please check out Barry it is
such an amazing show I can't get enough
of it and I I want more I've finished it
now I want more so please go watch that
I I I'm so mad at myself for forgetting
the actor's name but I saw NoHo Hank the
guy who plays NoHo Hank at a party one
time the even nicer than he is on the
show which is saying something without
the sort of murdery side too but just
such a sweetheart it's such a great show
and I know that that's going to appeal
to my co-host Jacqueline Coley's heart
because I don't know if you follow
Jacqueline Coley on social media kind of
a bill hater fan so she has that to
watch and Barry uh three tremendous
Seasons thus far and that's a great
recommendation for our show and a great
way to say good night here as I remind
you all that you can email us anytime
with your thoughts on shows you just
listen to what's your take on Batman
Returns let us know what other movies in
or outside the world of comic books we
should be talking about on the show hit
this up RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com is the email address
and if you're listening to us if you're
watching us thank you next week we're
covering a trio of movies with a guest
that I won't reveal today but let's just
say they're a big fan of this movie may
be surprising to some of you but not to
me and that would be the Mighty Ducks
Trilogy we're talking about the Mighty
Ducks D2 and D3 one of the only maybe
the only movie that's bought an actual
Championship winning franchise so we got
the Mighty Ducks next week for everybody
here including the great Claire limb at
we Claire Lucy Bruckner Lucy is our
producy Brian our engineering Brian
Perez for Jacqueline Coley I am Mark
Ellis the whole gang here at Rotten
Tomatoes thanks for watching Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong we'll see you next
time cute Catwoman's head popping up
from behind
foreign
[Music]